this is the Pacific Ocean
as far as oceans are concerned it's
definitely in my top five
you can swim in it surf on it or just
stare at it and think about your place
in the universe
one thing you might not immediately
think to do with the Pacific is drink
out of it and yet in the year 2016
that's exactly what the residents of San
Diego County will be doing we're
standing here at the site of the
Carlsbad desalination project the
largest seawater desalination facility
in the Western Hemisphere it will
produce up to 54 million gallons a day
that's enough to fill an Olympic sized
swimming pool every 18 minutes so it's
quite a significant new water supply for
a region everyone knows California is
going through a serious drought and has
been since 2013 but in spite of sitting
next to 187 quintillion gallons of water
in the Pacific Ocean desalination has
never been an obvious solution plants of
this scale are common in Israel and
Saudi Arabia but here in the US there's
never been anything like it is it fair
to say that Southern California now is
facing some of the same kinds of
challenges that places and even like the
deserts of the Middle East we're looking
at three decades ago this is a
Mediterranean climate and the way that
Southern California solved their water
resource issues historically was to
import water and that was available at
the time and it's not as reliable now
San Diego gets about 64% of its water
from the Colorado River eleven out of
the last 16 years on the Colorado River
have been drought years and so we like
to say the low-hanging fruit is gone
you've done all you can do with the
existing sources to some of you now you
actually need to create new sources of
water that's correct
so this is where it all happens yeah we
are in the reverse osmosis building this
is where we actually take out the soul
this is how every major desalination
plant in the world works you take in
seawater run it through reverse osmosis
and you're left with 50% fresh water and
50% super salty equational which gets
Reda looted and dumped back into the
ocean this is also where the whole idea
of converting seawater to drinking water
starts to remedy trouble the reverse
osmosis process requires a significant
amount of pressure and that pressure
requires energy we consume between 33
and 38 megawatts of power with the
single largest power user in San Diego
County
all that power costs money and this is
why sea water desalination has never
really worked in the u.s. we've always
had cheaper water sources available so
the developers of the Carlsbad plant
have spent about a billion dollars
trying to make it as efficient as it
possibly can be one key part of that
efficiency is this roomful of orange
twos
energy recovery devices by doing that
were able to recover about 40% of the
energy used to the plan mitigating a
considerable amount of energy that a
plant like this does require in spite of
all this efficiency desalinating water
still cost about 30 percent more than
importing it which means San Diego water
bills will go up when the plant comes
online and while generating 54 million
gallons of water per day may sound like
a lot it's actually only 10% of San
Diego's water needs so if you ask is the
salination the solution to California's
water crisis the answer is well no but
it will probably be a part of the
solution as climate change makes dry
places even drier we're going to reach
for whatever new water sources are
available even those that may seem
impractical today the future of
California's drought is uncertain but
what things for sure people will keep
looking out at those 187 quintillion
gallons of water and thinking